defense production act joining me now
Daniel Turner founder and executive
director of power of the future Daniel
now forget the invasion of the Southern
border 8 million in counting who've come
across carbon is the Real Enemy that we
need to Rally against and invoking a
Cold War era policy the defense
production act tell us about that yeah
and your analogy to what happened during
Co with masks is spoton once the
government is able to declare something
emergency it seems there powers are
Limitless you recall the government was
allowed to tell you to stop going to
church on Sunday they they kept you at
home they closed your business um and
only if you had powerful lobbyist
connections were you able to continue to
operate but otherwise the government was
in control and of course government
leaders Exempted themselves from those
Provisions right Governor Nome went to
dinner Nancy Pelosi got her hair done um
and so they're using the same power for
the climate and it's because it's power
right if you are a state if you believe
in in government power if you're a
little Tyrant as many in the Biden
Administration are look at the way they
use technology and the social media to
control your your freedom of speech if
you are a little Tyrant you love
invoking uh uh some sort of an emergency
because your Powers become absolutely
Limitless and this is what Biden is
doing now uh this is going to give like
more than $100 million in Grants and to
force the production of these um
electric heaters and electric heat pumps
electric stoves getting away from gas
stoves why is that important to them
really Daniel why is that such a bug in
bug in their Bonnet being their fossil
fuels fossil fuels are Freedom uh fossil
fuels are are the ability to move
undetected untethered by government
action right that's why the the
environmental left loves EVS because if
you have a gas- powerered car you can
just get in it and go but if you have an
electric car well we made decide whether
or not you get electricity we may decide
whether or not you can actually access
your car EVS that's why China loves
electric vehicles EVS are about control
fossil fuels are Freedom think of the
fossil fuels in your house heck you do
lose power but if you have a gas
powerered stove if you have a gas
powerered hot water heater life can
continue same with a gas powered
generator so they like uh the the
environmental movement likes all of
these electric powered things because it
makes you ring on government and it
makes you relying on them providing
electricity for you so this is the huge
push and you have to ask the president
or you you just showed that image of the
Secretary of Energy Jenifer grolm you
have to ask Jennifer grome if she's
watching if these were such viable
Technologies if they were so good why do
you have to force them why do you have
to use government action coercive action
to force them on us well they're
flopping and China's going to dominate
the EV Market they're they're already
beginning to but this is just breaking
before the show um New Jersey Advanced
media reporting that the state will
require all new car sales to be electric
all by 2035 Daniel they are coming for
your cars and now they want you to go EV
but soon they don't want you to have any
car at all if you ask me absolutely and
this is you know the government has to
use this Authority they have to use the
coercive power they have to force this
on the American people we did a poll on
this at powerthe future.com it was
overwhelmingly unpopular in New Jersey
we pulled new jerseyans and they oppose
this mandate because they like their
cars because they like their freedom and
America is a car culture right it's part
of our our 1960s rock and roll songs
they don't like America yeah they don't
like America they don't want America to
be free and they don't like freedom and
that is why theying is freedom of
movement freedom of Association no that
doesn't work with the New World Order
Daniel you've been on top of this from
the beginning uh we got to resist this
at hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else